翻訳: Shimajiri Michiaki
校正: Mizuho WATANABE
（三味線）
（音楽）
（拍手）
（雷鳴と雨音）
（三味線と笛）
（音楽）
（和太鼓）
（音楽が変わる）
（手拍子）
（拍手）
私が主宰を務める
MoB + stage project
という団体の
オープニングパフォーマンスを
ご覧いただきありがとうございます
皆さん いかがだったでしょうか？
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
申し遅れましたが
私 坪田知紗と申します
亡くなった父の会社を継いで
グラフィックなどのデザイン業務と
ダンスや舞台などの
イベント業務に従事し
アーティストの活動支援や
人材育成を目指して
活動を行なっています
ワクワクするような経験や
つらい経験を積み重ねてきた中で
ここまで歩き続けてこられた理由
そこには “環境”という
キーワードがありました
私は５歳の時に 生まれて初めて
劇団四季によるミュージカル
『キャッツ』を鑑賞し
猫たちの生き生きとした表情やダンス
そして歌に魅了され
将来はキャッツのお姉さんになりたいと
ピアノやダンス
演劇を学び始めました
中学演劇部に所属していた頃
全国で唯一のデザイン高専
札幌市立高等専門学校帰属のミュージカル部
現・劇団I'M（アイム）の
公演を見る機会がありました
デザインと舞台が
絶妙にミックスされた
ステージに魅了され
猛勉強の末 高専に入学し
そして劇団I'Mに入団しました
札幌高専はドイツにある
造形学校バウハウスの
早期教育に影響を受けた
デザイン学校です
なぜ早期教育が必要だったのでしょうか？
十代の後半の時期というのは
子どもから大人へと変化する
大切な準備期間です
自我があるので 反発心もありますが
叱られても 素直に聞き入れることのできる
最後の時期とも言えるでしょう
例えば 私自身のことを振り返ると
それまでの人生において
“気遣い”という考え方が
まったくありませんでした
それなので 周りの人々に
言動の全てを注意される毎日でした
先生や先輩方から叱咤を受け
ふてくされながらも
自分の言動に責任を
持つことの大切さを
学んだ記憶があります
劇団ではデザイナーの卵たちが
自由な発想を持ち寄り
衣装や舞台美術 そして
音楽や映像制作などを行ない
感性をいかした総合芸術としての
舞台創作を行なっていました
各部署 細かく担当が分かれており
新入生を迎え入れるために
毎年 『ミュージカルのABC』という
マニュアル本を作成していました
内容はストレッチの図解から
音響コードの八の字巻きの方法まで
多岐にわたる知識を
各部署のリーダーが
本やビデオなどから学び
一冊の本として
まとめ上げていたのです
そして 十代の若者たちが切磋琢磨をし
決して受け身にならず
独自の練習手法を
産み出すことによって
急速に成長を遂げ
プロ顔負けの舞台創作を
行っていました
勉学にも舞台創作にも
恵まれた環境の中で
当の私は 周りの才能にあてられ
目標・自信を失なっていました
このように奇抜なファッションに身を包み
そして授業をサボり
先生の助言も顧みず
「自由を校風とした学校で どうして
怒られなければいけないんだ」
と思っていました
今からすると とても
恥ずかしいことですが
当時の私にとっては
アイデンティティの現れだったのです
そんな時 入学式の時に
副校長先生がおっしゃった言葉が
頭をよぎりました
自由とは好き放題に
自分勝手をすることではなく
自らを律する 自立することで
初めて得られるもの
当時の私は完全に自由を
はき違えていたのです
札幌高専卒業後
ニューヨーク[での]ダンス留学を経て
現在はダンスを教える仕事をしています
留学時代に ダンスの本場にて
表現力・技術力・指導力を学んできた
という自負があったので
最初は自信に満ちあふれていました
縁があって 子どもたちに
チアダンスという
点数や順位を競う競技ダンスを
教える機会がありました
そのチアダンスを教える中で
徐々に自信を失っていきました
このチアダンスというのは
ダンステクニックや
チームの一体感などが問われる—
ダンス技術だけではなくて
チーム力が問われるダンスでした
どんどん順位を上げ
世界でもトップレベルの
チームに育っていく中
どうしてもチーム格差が
生まれ始めました
試行錯誤をし
一生懸命 いろんなアプローチの仕方で
伝える努力をしましたが
練習に集中してくれない
自主練習をしてくれない
挨拶や返事をしてくれない
無反応 無表情
そんな状況が続きました
一方的に押しつけるような言い方に
なっていたのかもしれません
手をとり協力し合うはずの
仲間と不仲になり
自信を失ってダンスをやめてしまった
生徒たちが何人もいます
私自身 頑張れば
頑張るほど 空回りして
体調を崩し 過呼吸になった
ようなこともあります
そして忘れもしない12月23日の予選大会
私の担当チームは
数年ぶりに予選落ちをしてしまいました
ビデオ審査に臨めば
再び 全国大会への切符を
勝ち取ることができる
という瀬戸際でしたが
主要メンバーのほとんどが
「もうこんなチームにはいたくない
これ以上傷つきたくない」
と言って泣きじゃくり
親御さんたちも完全に
疲弊しきっていました
私も不甲斐なさに いたたまれない
気持ちでいっぱいでした
まさにチーム解散の危機
でもチャンスは１つだけ残されている
それなのにチャンスを棒に振るなんて！
それに こんな気持ちのまま
終わるなんて悲しすぎる
すぐに決断をしなければいけなかったため
イブとクリスマス当日は
電話で子どもたち一人一人と
何時間も話して 説得をして
何とか全員でビデオ審査に臨み
全国大会への切符を
勝ち取ることができたのです
ただし まだまだ試練は
残されていました
改めて“成長のための環境づくりとは”
と考える日々です
そんな頃 高専時代の先生方と
お酒を飲み交わし
教育方針について議論する
機会がありました
同じ先生という立場で学生たちに
どのように向き合っていたのかを
伺ったところ
「僕たちは君たちに対して
『ああしろ こうしろ』と
口うるさく言わなかった
できる限り自由に学べる
環境づくりのために
試行錯誤していたよ」
とおっしゃっていました
私はその話の中で 方向性の間違いに
ハッとさせられたのです
ここで気がついたのは
自主性を重んじる
環境を作ることの大切さ
そして先生としての姿勢でした
今では副校長先生が
おっしゃっていた言葉が
はっきりと理解できます
私たちはつい “相手を変えよう”
“成長させよう”と考えがちです
一人の先生という立場になって初めて
高専という環境づくりを担っていた
先生方の偉大さを感じました
先ほどお話したチアダンスチームも
教育の環境を見直して
そして全国大会では何とか
順位と点数を上げることができ
何よりも全員で最後まで
まっとうすることができました
またニューヨークでは
先生方が生徒に交じって
他の先生のクラスを受講するような
姿がよく見受けられました
どの先生方も生徒以上に
真剣に向きあっており
いつも学ぶ姿勢を忘れない
先生方の姿に感動しました
“相手を変えよう”ではなく
“自分が変わる努力をすること”が大切なのです
親の背中を見て育つ
という言葉がありますが
先生も同様です
いい環境と理解者があれば
人は自然と育つもの
そして人の成長が
自分自身の成長につながる
ということを発見しました
「環境づくりの心得３箇条」
自ら考え 工夫し
仲間と共に成長できるように促すこと
上手くいかない時こそ
自分自身の在り方を見つめ直すこと
困っている時は 手を差し伸べること
以上の点に気をつけながら
今は自ら主宰する団体にて
より良い学びの環境をめざし
活動を行なっています
具体的には 先生が一から十まで
全てを教えようとすると
子どもたちは常に受け身になり
自主性が失われてしまいます
例えば ストレッチのリードを任せたり
振り付けを考える機会を与えることで
ダンサーとしてだけではなく
指導者や振付師としての能力も
引き出せるよう環境を整えています
先ほどのオープニングパフォーマンスも
振り付けの一部を子どもたちが担っています
ダンス以外にも 英語やメイクや
お絵かきが得意な子など
子どもたちは才能豊かです
才能を見いだし 個性を生かして
英語でのレッスンを行ってもらったり
メイク案の考案や
舞台美術制作の手伝いを
してもらったりしています
次に—
ダンス技術向上のための
環境づくりとは
答えは簡単です
個人のレベルを見極め
出来そうで出来ない程度の
レベル設定のクラスに入れることです
周りは うまい人ばかり
正直言って とても焦ります
ですが 自分にぴったりの
クラスにずっといると
ぬるま湯に漬かったまま
出てこられなくなってしまいます
逆に全然できない もしくは
ゴールが全く見えないような
クラスにいると
自信を失い モチベーションが
下がってしまいます
自分よりも少し上級レベルの
人たちが集う
環境に放り込まれることで
身近な目標が出来上がり
そして達成を目指して
頑張れるようになります
ダンスや絵が上手な人は
世の中にたくさんいます
何が違いを生むかというと
個性や人間性です
私の恩師は こう言いました
リーダーの使命は
次なるリーダーを育てること
私もそう思います
人の一生は限られていますが
次の世代へのバトンタッチが続いていけば
ダンスや身体表現の力で
世の中を良くしていけると
信じています
人が育つための環境づくりには
ゴールはありません
よりよい環境づくりについて
皆さんも考えていただければ幸いです
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）